I smiled because I'm probably the only
one running for president who took an
issue to the democratic platform
personally and ask them to act on it.
And let me tell you what the issue was.
Healthcare in 2000
I took this proposal for a not for
profit healthcare system,
medicare for ah,
to the Democratic Platform Committee.
I was asked by the campaign,
the presidential candidate to withdraw
the proposal because it was,
it was not favored by the insurance
interest who were contributing mightily
to the Democratic Party.
And,
and virtually the same thing happened in
2004 so here's the Democratic Party.
These candidates are saying universal
healthcare,
like it's some kind of mantra,
universal healthcare,
universal healthcare.
And then people go,
oh,
they're for me.
They're going to give me a universal
healthcare.
The insurance companies want universal
healthcare as long as the government is
subsidizing them so they can maintain
theirs.
They're holding their privilege profit
position.
I'm talking about no more healthcare for
profit.
Everyone knows these insurance companies
make money not providing health care.
Everyone knows it.
So I'm saying no more for profit
healthcare,
not for profit system.
All the money goes into care for people.
And then you have enough money,
not only for basic care but for vision
care,
dental care,
mental health care,
longterm care,
prescription drugs,
all covered 100% under the cassette,
which program the Democrats new.
They want to protect the insurance
company.
I don't know that,
uh,
that I accept much of the platform of
either party,
but I will tell you this,
that I work with Republicans in Congress
who stands for protecting the
constitution were absolutely opposed to
the Patriot Act who believe that wire
tapping eavesdropping is an undermining
of constitutional protections to be free
from your person for unreasonable search
searches and seizures who believe that,
um,
uh,
that,
that government functions best when it
stays out of people private lives.
So that aspect,
which seems to go more towards,
you know,
what Republicans think,
the things that,
that I support.
And I,
and I also think that,
uh,
that this idea of,
of,
of Democrats and Republicans a good idea
as long as there's a real debate,
but when the debate becomes blurred
because you have corporate interest
contributing two Democrats and two
Republicans,
then you have the American people being
deserved than people in those parties
maintained their privileged position.
Well,
the economic status of their
constituents begins to erode.